You know those fuel guzzling, smoke-spewing modes of transportation we call cars?
Despite threats of climate change, automobiles and trucks aren't going away any time soon.
But some of the pollution caused by these road warriors is.
There's a whole new generation of autos promising carbon free emissions...
...and some of them are even fun to drive.
I think people feel really good about driving a vehicle...
...that is also very socially responsible.
Something that's fun, something that looks good,...
...but something that can make them feel like...
...they're really contributing to making the world a better place.
This is the Tesla Roadster,...
...an all - electric vehicle that can go more than 400 kilometers on a charge.
The car is made out of carbon fiber.
That's very unique to this particular vehicle.
It makes the vehicle very light which helps out with the performance.
The Tesla is named after inventor Nikola Tesla,...
...one of the early pioneers of electrical power.
The Tesla is a great-looking car...
...and despite its size, it has ample storage for a weekend getaway, or...
You have enough storage space here to fit actually...
...two golf bags, one on top of the other, so...
...you can absolutely fit weekend bags and travel with this vehicle for the weekend.
...more importantly, at least to race car fans,...
...the Tesla Roadster has all the torque of a 500 horsepower Corvette.
And the Tesla can go from zero to 100 kilometers per hour...
...in less than four seconds.
By any measure, that's fast.
The hardest thing is to not get a speeding ticket.
The Roadster has its drawbacks though,...
...namely the price: more than 100,000 US dollars.
But in 2011, Tesla Motors will offer a roomier, more family friendly car...
...at half the price.